this is joint work as you said with
Daniel was in the audience and it's a
very simple stochastic spatial model
about I think a basic process in
evolution and adaptation more
specifically when you have adaptation by
new beneficial mutations then what you
need to have is that a new mutation
that's initially we r becomes frequent
okay and it's important question to ask
how fast is that process because there
are many regimes where this time where
you know initially rare variant becomes
very frequent dominate so controls how
fast adaptation of course and when we
think about this process normally in
population genetics we think okay a new
variant which is unconditionally
beneficial it will spread exponentially
when we do that then we have you know
the assumption that more or less the
population is well mixed every video in
tax rate with every other individual and
then naturally you get exponential
growth that then saturates after some
time but when you have space when space
is important and you have limited
dispersal then you slow down and this
talks about how fast how quickly you
slow down when you have long-range
dispersal there is a very important
regime which has been understood quite
well that is when you have only local
with a local dispersal so meaning that
sort of your dispersal kernel is for
instance Gaussian you only jump to your
neighboring site or not very far away
and then you get travelling waves but
this is about exploring other regimes
that come about when you have broader
dispersal kernels okay so the basic
process I have in mind is illustrated
here it's imagine you have a resident
population which is the flu one and then
a new type appears which is more
reactive reproducing faster and then
it's clear if it survives the initial
phase okay the initial phase where
the mutant or this variant has to
struggle with fluctuations genetic drift
to even establish when that has occurred
then it will just deterministically
spread across space it's a super
critical process i'm considering here
the question is how fast is that so i
think the initial phase you know
establishment of beneficial mutations is
also very interesting and there's so
many things to explore actually in
spatial systems but I'm only going to
talk about essentially this later stage
where you then have established and the
game is to expand in the population and
that occurs in many contexts so I've
just framed the problem in thinking
about spreading of an advantageous
mutation and that has been started by
Ronald Fisher kolmogorov and PP his goon
off and the last P I forgot it off
exactly so and they did this in 1937 i
will mention that model later and many
work has followed up on that and and and
there in the audience people obviously
that have thought a lot about this as
well this particular process and most of
these other spatial processes as well
which are in a way equivalent there are
new twists that come into the problem so
for instance if you think about
epidemics the spread of infectious
disease then what this process here
corresponds to is an SI model we have a
susceptible type and infected type that
comes in and then essentially you have a
chemical reaction where s plus i has a
tendency to go to to I the reverse you
know s plus I can also go to 2 I 2 s but
this is sort of more likely and then you
get spreading of the I type and in
epidemics you have to think about other
more complicated models as well we have
also the process where in fact it goes
to recover it and I will touch on that
in the last couple of slides as well but
for now let's focus on the simplest kind
of epidemic reaction epidemic spread
that
that can occur also this process
essentially happens when you have the
spread of an invasive species that
introduced into some virgin territory
and then the s-type essentially is empty
space that gets displaced by the
invasive species also you can imagine
spread of information gossip and also
there a number of people in the audience
could have worked on that or ideas that
you see perfectly what Tom elders for
instance has or something so the
question I'm going to ask is how fast is
that process in the presence of
long-range dispersal let's first think
about this epidemic scenario and look at
how it happened in the past so this is a
reconstructed map of how the bubonic
plague spread in the 14th century from
the south south of Europe to the north
and from this reconstruction based on
historical record it looks like okay
it's brett morris wave like and it
rather slowly so it took like advanced
on the order of 300 to 600 kilometers
per year compare that with for instance
the spread of SARS in two thousand i
think to write it merged in in a
province in china and then first spread
locally but until it more as infected a
person that went on the play plane moved
to other places and then it spread very
quickly across the globe and spread
essentially within six months to many
places across the world so what's the
big difference between these two
scenarios of course different diseases
but it's likely that the dispersal
mechanism is what makes a big difference
so in the past what you could do is you
could walk or you could take a horse
okay you could also take a ship and then
you can move away still further it shows
you that really long range this pressure
dispersal can be rarely excluded but
today it's more evident oh this is very
pixelized this image it's in reality
much more
beautiful this depicts the avian
transport networks of airplanes across
the world and they are supposed to
should be able Zhan the better picture
you would be able to see like big
circles for big airports and thick lines
for strong connections but what do you
still see that you know there are lots
of connections and long-distance
connections in particular and this leads
to dispersal that is long range okay
it's very hard to measure really
precisely how humans move across the
globe but what has been done for
instance is a study where people track
the traveling of dollar bills in the
u.s. so you might have seen single
dollar bills which have on them a stamp
it's actually saying where's where's
george okay and and then a number okay
and when you see that you can principal
go online to a website and record that
number and the place where you found the
dollar bill and in the undead website
they essentially storing that
information and originally it was just a
hobby of a couple of people that started
this until essentially one study
realized this is a great resource of
information which you can use to to
study essentially how dot dollar bills
at least travel across the u.s. and from
that perhaps infer how humans actually
moving so at least in the case of dollar
bills what they found is that they
disperse according to a distribution
which has a broad tail so P of our here
is the range over which a single dollar
bill travels in a fixed amount of time
the time they chose for this plot was
four days I think and you see on this
double log plot that it has a broad tail
that seems to have a power tail at least
over two orders of magnitude with an
exponent what- 1.6 so the question I
want to raise in a very simple model is
how can we explain the qualitative
difference between these two scenarios
here and the insuring epidemic
evolutionary spread I think that's here
they chose a different time of spread
and just to show that essentially they
get the same exponent so to let me
anticipate very simple simulations that
I show you more off later on we're
essentially have a two-dimensional
lattice and in the center there's a
little dot so it's seated by just one
occupied site and then all the
simulation does is it randomly in each
time step in randomly selects a source
site then draws from a dispersal Colonel
a jump distance and select the target
side and if the source side is occupied
in the target side not when the target
size becomes filled and that's continued
over and over again and on the left and
for both simulations I choose dispersal
Colonel's Colonels which have a broad
Taylor power law tail but on the left
the tail is relatively steep and on the
right it's very relatively broad so that
you will see a qualitative difference
there so let me start the left movie so
as the population growing you see it's
very very noisy and you get longer range
jumps but if this grows further than on
after a long time and if you look at
large distances it really just looked
like a growing pancake that grows
essentially at a constant speed they're
pretty noisy there but coarse grain this
is becomes asymptotically a circle but
it's very it's going to be very
different here on the right
so again little circle in the beginning
but then suddenly everywhere clusters
appear and grow and merge and this looks
like you know call it metastatic grows
like everywhere clusters emerge and that
of course speeds up the the overall
growth of the occupied regions and they
are merging ultimately and the game that
we have to understand ultimately is
really how these new class disappears
and merge together to understand this
overall overall growth growth yes
exactly it's in this simple simple model
is just one it's like a more as a
contact process with long-range jumps
and before I go into this let me just go
back in time a little bit and described
in just one dimensions how you might
model the spread in the case we have
just short range dispersal and that was
pioneered by as I said Fisher kolmogorov
and PP and they modeled essentially the
spread of a population of beneficial
mutations by in a continuum in the
continuum limit by a density sea of
space X and time T and they argued that
the rate of change of sorry it's not yet
noisy it's just a traveling wave at this
point deterministically so they argued
that the rate of change of this density
profile should be given by two terms one
is essentially diffusion so this is the
second derivative of the density with
respect to space and a second term which
describes local logistic growth so when
the density is small you grow
exponentially at a rate art but then
when the density approaches the limiting
value and the growth turtle disappears
and you only have diffusion so that's
occurring here in the saturated region
and okay this simple model gives rise to
traveling waves that travel at a
constant speed
asymptotically and the speed can be even
calculated exactly by folk focusing on
the tip of this wave and already from
dimensional analysis you can see that
the only way you can get a speed from
these two parameters diffusion constant
which is the length squared over time
and the growth rate R which is one over
time is by forming this combination and
then okay you have this factor of two in
front and then 70 years later it was
realized for it is the importance was
realized that really particles are
discrete typically in many applications
and that introduces an important noise
term in this in the continuum limit
which can have different forms but you
always have this piece that the noise
term is proportional to the square root
of the density and it is a space time
dependent Gaussian noise term here and
this noise program essentially
represents genetic drift which is very
crucial here in the tip of the wave and
really affects the behavior of the whole
wave and the reason for that is that the
wave is really pulled forward by the
dynamics that's going on here in these
founder cells and in the founders the
number the individual the total number
of founder cells is always in a sense
small even if the carrying capacity is
very large so this noise term is hardly
ever negligible and it was shown that it
leads to a very strong correction to
this traveling wave speed which scales
in this form so k here is the carrying
capacity its maximum density of the
population here in the bag of wave and
you cannot get this term for instance by
a perturbation analysis if you assume
this is a small perturbation and cannot
get this term it's a singular
perturbation so it's important here this
kind of noise and now you might wonder
okay can be in this framework go on
perhaps to discuss what happens when we
have long-range dispersion dispersal
okay a natural modification would be to
replace this diffusion term by an
integral term which essentially sums up
all the influx 2x from other places due
to jumps ok and the jumps that we are
going we are going to describe the jumps
by a function G of a vector and that
describes the probability density of
obtaining a jump of a certain distance
in a certain direction so this is a wake
to you but then the problem becomes even
harder and most of the approaches to
this point have simply neglected them
this noise term and assumed for a
particular reason that the dispersal
kernel has a power law form of this type
first of all we will also make this
convention that you say okay but this
dispersal kernel has a tail that scales
like distance to the power of minus and
a new plus dimension we're talking about
if you choose this parameterization then
the dispersal kernel will be integral be
normalizable if mu is larger than 0 and
the variance will be finite as long as
mu is larger than two and these many
people thought in the past okay new
behavior only appears when this exponent
knew when the variance becomes infinite
so the focus on the case most of them
focus on the case mule smaller than two
and they invariably found exponential
growth exponential growth of the total
population as soon as you have these
longer long distance jumps there was
another approach which used a hog
approximation that worked or that works
in the case of short-range dis dispersal
and that is the approach to assume okay
we can effectively describe the effect
of noise by using a deterministic
equation which has a cut-off where the
noise term sorry the growth term has a
cut off when the density becomes smaller
than a certain limiting density then we
add a cut off which essentially makes
this growth curve disappear
heuristically arguing that ok out there
that are not in the video anymore
mollison is important one who said who
looked into the settin em who who looked
at this question and ask the question ok
when become will dispersal become very
important and he found that in one day
when you get when you have a dispersal
colonel that's broader than X or as
broad as an exponential exponentially
decaying this decay in distribution you
get exponential growth so also
consistent with these results but what
you know these simulations very quickly
show is that if you neglect noise that
doesn't reach you know then you're not
even close to to the simulation results
and the reason is simply that these mean
field approaches in way they neglect the
discreteness of the long-range jump and
let me first show simulation results and
then I try to give you a flavor of a
very simple argument to to that it's
actually reproduces the behaviors that
we see in the simulations ok I
essentially explained the simulations
already and then you just do it again so
yeah we have a two dimensional letters
in two dimension we focus on square
lattice we start with one occupied side
and then we draw repeatedly source and
target sites the distance is drawn from
this dispersal distribution and then we
just keep going and the dispersal kernel
that we choose has a paula tail with an
exponent parameterize in this way
and that illustration here doesn't
really add much it just says that the
short-range part of the dispersal kernel
will give rise in the space-time plot to
most cone like structure but then from
these more rare long-range jumps you get
new seeds new clusters emerging that
then merge but let me just show you now
directly simulations with three
exponents and all these three
simulations will illustrate three
different regimes that occur so this is
a the case where the dispersal range so
the dispersal kernel is rather steep and
it will give rise to a growing pancake
here the variance diverges in 2d and we
get a very chaste growth which I called
metastatic in the past and here we also
get something which is much faster than
linear growth but notice the variance of
the dispersal kernel is still finite so
let me start all of them together so
this one finishes first simulation stops
I think when seventy percent of the
lattice is filled and here second one
you clearly see if not anymore it looks
like growing circle at all and here we
have much slower growth we can analyze
these simulations very simply by
defining something like an effective
radius so essentially just what you do
here is we take the total number of
occupied sites and take essentially the
square root of that to get an effective
radius and you see how it's growing here
on a linear linear scale the slowest
growth here seems to be consistent as
importantly with a linear growth and I
show you much larger scale simulations
lighter on that really are consistent
with that on a log-log scale really just
for that simulation that I've shown you
here you see that the two lower ones
seem to be approaching straight lines
but the middle one here has
higher exponent so that's indeed what we
will find a power law super linear power
law that that regime and on a semi
logarithmic plot where the y-axis is
logarithmic but here's just time you see
that even the fastest growing case the
blue line here does not seem to approach
a straight line okay and indeed what we
find is this is described by stretched
exponential so where the logarithm of
the total occupy area grows like a power
log with an exponent smaller than one
and now give you let me give you a very
simple argument to that will result in
an approximation that reproduces the
simulation results at least two leading
oil so let's look at this occupied
region that's generated by this process
in a spacetime plot okay space here's on
the x-axis and time on the y-axis and
I'm assuming here that essentially the
occupied region grows like this funnel
here so the boundaries of the funnel are
not straight because I'm assuming now
that the occupancy grows faster than
linear so it has to be bent in this way
and this band is very important and what
I'm also assuming in this illustration
one can do better than that but what I'm
assuming here is essentially if one
fully occupied core and then outside
surely there will be some density but in
this plot I'm in this illustration I'm
neglecting it for now and then let's ask
what happens if you have out of this
funnel a long-range jump for instance
this one here if you have a jump that
occurs and that is successful so the
seed survives essentially genetic drift
in our simulations always does then you
know in this approximation we say what
we should do is we should copy and paste
this funnel to the point where we jumped
if you do this in this case then you see
that this emerging funnel here will
contain this grey circle here so so
that's great circle here she plays
important roles for the argument that's
the head point t that's the typical
radius of the occupied region okay and
now I want to make an argument that
gives me a relation for or condition for
this typical radius at time T okay so in
this argument things about a people
which ways can i get this grey circle
occupied this is just one way i can get
a long-range jump relatively late on a
seat here and then i have to copy and
paste this funnel there and it will
contain the grey circle great circles
occupied that's fine another possibility
is a very long jump very early on and
the funnel will contain the grey circle
or this situation here all of these
three ways are individually have a very
low probability but what you're
interested in is all the ways you can
get the grey circle to be colonized if
you think about that then you find the
condition that you must have is that you
get a jump from this red region which we
call source area into this blue area
that's the pic is there and this blue
area turns out geometrically to have
exactly the same shape as this red
funnel it's only flipped around the
horizontal it's very easy to see that
this must be the correct shape by this
copy and paste process so take this
funnel for instance and copy it to
directly this boundary here and then
draw the funnel there and would
precisely cut through the Great Circle
because because of symmetry essentially
and that symmetry is also important for
the argument as I will show in a second
and now this self-consistency argument
is simply to say okay if this assumed
growth of the funnel is more or less
correct then what we must have is
that the total probability to get a jump
from the source area to the target area
should be of order one okay that's the
argument because if this total
probability would be much larger than 1
then we would say okay then the assumed
funnel shape must be faster growing
because you get these gems much more
quickly if the total probability is much
smaller than one you would say well then
the assumed shape was too large okay and
the argument can be formulated
mathematically very easily you just have
to calculate this probability and set it
to be one so the total probability to
jump from red to blue to calculate that
I need an integral over time from 0 to T
and then to space integrals one is over
the red region it's the first one and
another one over the blue region and
then I have to integrate over the
probability density to get the
associated jumps so that's where the
jump colonel workers and this gives you
one condition for each time T and it
really constrains the dynamics of the
whole growth process except for the
initial conditions for which you need
and really the short-term part
short-range part of the growth but still
it's an integral equation hide resolve
in general but when these funnels are
growing very very quickly there's an
additional effect that helps you namely
that most of the crucial jumps will
actually occur pre Maddux much exactly
at half time which is another another
way of saying this is that this time
integral here is a very pronounced peak
at T half when the funnel growth very
very rapidly the reason is simply that
on short times it's the source stump
funnel that is very small and therefore
getting jumps at all is very rare and at
large time it's the target funnel we
have to jump into it's very small
and because you know the integrins here
essentially a product of total occupied
mass and total target area what you get
is ultimately a pronounced peak and by
symmetry it has to be a tea half so what
you can do is a saddle point
approximation so sorry so this equation
now gets in this limit where you're very
fast growth it gets to be replaced by
this much simpler expression and you can
directly interpret this product on the
right again it's supposed to represent
the total probability of getting a jump
from the red region to the blue region
and we are carrying out a saddle point
approximation so meaning that the jumps
at the crucial jumps happen at T half so
you need to essentially i multiply here
the size of the source region at t half
which is L of T half to the power of the
dimension with the total area of the
target region at the same time which is
to say okay so we just get out of tea
half to the power to D for this product
we have to multiply it for the
probability to get a jump by what
distance the distance of typically L of
T and we have to multiply we need
another time factor in the front from
the saddle point approximation and now
if you know okay that now we don't have
to choose a power-law distribution for
this colonel but it's convenient to
classify the behaviors and that's what
we're doing now so if you insert for
this dispersal Colonel a power law which
is as I described before then we end up
with this very simple recurrence
relation of L of time T in terms of L at
time T half okay that's the argument and
this in fact can be solved exactly any
questions about the argument at this
point because now I'm going to
results so for the results let's first
look at the solution to this equation in
the limit of very large times
essentially the asymptotics because
they're actually rigorous results exist
and so there are many regimes so these
rigorous results have been proven by
marek bisque open 2014 t by chettayii
dye into the last year's on the archive
so let me go through these awesome
tortics that case by case so let's start
in the regime where this exponent mu is
smaller than d this is the fastest
growth regime there you find that the
log of the diameter the effective
diameter grows like a power law with an
exponent given by this expression there
that and a prefect of being knew that
you get out of this argument the
behavior here the power behavior also
appears in supercritical long-range
percolation and with the same exponent
and the model by chitali and I really is
it's framed differently but it really
maps onto our epidemic model as well and
they could also prove that this is the
correct asymptotic that power law but
the prefactor is actually important
because it turns out as you move towards
the boundary it's going to going to
diverge which signals a very slow
crossover which I'm talking about later
yes originally of the power law when u
is less than 2
use the intuition that variance was
Infinite but now you seem to have sort
of switched it seems like it turns out
that this is not a crucial distinction
for the variance is finite or infinite
but it was just totally people assumed
from thinking about random or just
random books without reaction but when
you have reaction and resin box it
doesn't matter if it's different
conditions that night then I'm a paper
and I'm i righted that was partly
because they happen to be doing all
their simulations in two dimensions
right because you before you talk about
muse less than two and I cannot use less
than D no no so for in any dimensions
when you're in the parametric approach
parametrization to choose but new is
more than two of the variances coming
internet right they did they thought
about any dementia that I guess they did
simulations on Bundy maybe
okay then if the if the exponent means
between D and D plus 1 you get power log
growth with an exponent given by this
expression and again the asymptotic
exponent a power line is proven by chata
yet done a really very nice work and but
again the prefect is important that
diverges at both boundaries and for
larger than mu larger than D plus 2 you
get indeed just linear growth with a
speed that's going to be dependent
should've written that they're also an
exponent and the speed is gone at the
verge as you approach the boundary there
the been very turns out very importantly
are actually the marginal cases when mu
is exactly equal to do the 2d then you
get a growth where the log of the
diameter grows like log squared of time
so very funny functional form here
within again important pre factor which
depends on the dimension and here for at
the other boundary the diameter grows
like t log T now these are the
asymptotics they describe the behavior
very long times but it turns out at
finite times the behavior looks a little
bit different so I'm plotting this here
for the behavior essentially as a
function of this exponent new and I'm
choosing here a variable delta which
essentially measures how far is mu from
d okay so mu equals to D is precisely a
boundary between stretch exponential and
super linear growth and the limit where
T goes to infinity okay that's what I
described before that's as imperfect but
in the asymptotic and asymptotic times
the marginal k is really just matters
that mu exactly equal to 2 D it turns
out that for finite times the marginal
case blows up and represents a very
important intermediate as I'm Tata
okay so if you start here for instance
and run your dynamics at first you just
deepen the marginal case and then cross
over to the super linear growth and
actually the relaxation time is very
very large so the log of this relaxation
time goes like 2d / this from the Delta
and and it turns out that for instance
if Delta is less than point 3 it is
essentially impossible to get out of the
marginal case and simulations and even
more more so in nature so in nature that
you're essentially by the time you get
out of the marginal case then your
system or you're occupied regions so
large larger than 10 to the 9 that it
cannot matter at least on earth you know
it perhaps in the world still but yeah
so it's really important then to have a
fully dynamical equation that describes
the growth of this occupied region and
that is shown here so this essentially
the solution to that recurrence relation
that I introduced before it describes a
simple equation for the log size of this
effective diameter in terms of the log
time that has elapsed and it's given by
that expression and it entails these
different regimes as emphatically that I
described to you but also the dynamics
here and we can we can test it by
running simulations and of course I can
prove we did in one we did simulations
in one and 2d and both agree pretty well
but in 1d of course i can get too much
larger systems by the simulations i
described so here you see the
simulations on a semi logarithmic plot
and the exponents I chose was point six
point seven point eight point nine one
would be exactly the marginal case don't
know why I left it out here and then 1.1
and
on to 1.4 and it agrees pretty well with
the data so I plotted here individual
runs for each case ten individual runs
and so you get some spread here but the
predictions line pretty nicely on top of
each other but on a double log scale you
see for instance that for these cases
here ok let's look at this blue line so
what do they mean for these cases here
as importantly we expect a power law
with a particular exponent power law in
a double log plot looks like a straight
line and for these cases are indicated
the asymptotic exponent by these blue
lines here ok and you see that for this
case for instance which is one point why
in one even though we have simulated up
to 10 10 to the 7 roughly we are not
even close to this asymptotic parlor
regime so or you'll hear the furthest
portable from the emergent or so this is
just the total mass of the population
and this is also an interesting question
to what differs you know these are
further questions i'm not talking about
these it let me to get the first one
yeah and there's a much better test
which i don't show here actually which
applies to a test for the fear the best
test fit for this theory for this
argument at least is when you are very
close to the marginal case because then
this function your collapses onto a
scaling for where you can essentially
plot data from different exponents in
one plot and the different data will
essentially map out different effective
times in that plot and then the
prediction would be that they all
collapse on one curve and
that's indeed the case and you can look
at the preprint if you want to see that
I can also if you're interested show
that in the question section how much
time do I have we start a bit late right
yeah 500 okay so let me get quickly
that's just summary of what we had you
can by extending the argument you can
also describe the density profiles are
not just a core which is essentially one
and then assumes it's more like zero but
you can describe the density outside the
score the expectation for that and you
have here a couple of nice plots in 3d
but let me just mention further things
that it could be done or should be done
so so far I just looked at the SI model
but you can easily imagine what happens
if you now have in this epidemic
framework also recovered individuals
then you have a process where I goes to
our okay and then what you effectively
do you burn a cone of recovered in the
videos in the source funnel which
changes the geometry metric picture it's
not anymore the case that you have these
totally identical areas and the saddle
point approximation you can still do a
set of point approximation you don't
have this exact symmetry anymore and
then this particular case as
emphatically really maps onto what was
described by marek biskup it was super
critical long-range population and also
in simulation that this has been shown
to work very nicely by class burger
recently but what this argument that we
present thus in addition is you can now
describe the crossover from initial
where you have just in this i model to
the SI our model and get important
praefectus on principle i think there's
no way no obstacle of extending this to
other epidemic frameworks other things
that i think would be interesting to
look at our infection trees so what kind
of genealogies are generated by this
process so here again here I not again
but here i show you how you can from
these simulations i showed
reconstruct essentially a colonization
path so what I did here is in the
original seat was in the center then I
sampled here equidistantly 100 points
and reproduce the colonization path and
that gives you essentially this very
nice cual essen tree and the thickness
here represents how many leaves are
essentially hanging on that branch and
really looks tree like here and a couple
of properties about these trees are
understood like for instance the bush
eNOS let's call it where you can
describe essentially the transfer is
with of this tree in terms of the radial
distance a regular size of the tree
scaling behaviors and I stood for this
kind of dynamics but then you can ask
the question how does this change when
you go into these other regimes so here
i show you reproduce coalescence tree or
infection trees for these other
scenarios and i think this would be
important because you know all the
sequence data of spreading fire
epidemics that are mutating quickly and
in principle you can imagine sampling
these viruses get DNA genetic
information on genetic diversity and try
to reproduce these these trees and then
potentially colonization path and also
what's nice about this actually very
dumb model is that you get naturally in
a way hops right you get have to
individuals that are not in any way
special but still they are crucial for
infecting a large portion of the
population many there are a number of
models that were papers that point out
okay there are people that are
representing hops and there might be
something special about them but even in
these simple models with long-range
migration can get many other things on
the horizon perhaps is you know how does
hitchhiking work in these regimes what
about soft sweeps when you have multiple
mutations occur
in space what happens when they spread
at the same time that's very well
understood by peter roff and Graham cool
plenty of our in this regime of
traveling waves in language but what
happens in these other regimes when you
grow faster than that but still not
where exponential is in the well mixed
case what about clonal interference and
what about data would really be nice to
have an epidemic that they actually can
be used to so you wanna release if you
could do that in the lab with also
covariance let let me thank you again
then your for collaboration and I take
questions so I don't know yet because i
have hadn't worked out there's still a
question mark yeah but I I guess because
the behaviors of this tree will be
pretty different so how many you know
leaves how many the bushing is more less
of these trees will be very different I
mean roughly speaking might be able to
see this here already if you compare
these but I expect to us to be able to
do this not very precisely but you might
be able to say okay new is more than
this one the regime first the second or
third there's no relationship between
the
it would be nice I don't know if I knew
I don't have a quick argument for that
setting new simulations that when you go
to jump it always somehow is that bad in
the simulation they are done in this way
and if I talk about that to happen to I
just think by 2 times the selection
coefficient that would be one way of
doing that but essentially what we have
in orders for dispersal Colonel
especially the product of the two things
so which makes it faster so if you would
always jump and then not do anything
with a Japanese lo tomas instead of
instead of long-range interaction
colonel use stochasticity which has
heavy care of my classifieds combined
directly with that cake in the equation
who can be analogous you can be the same
so you want to combine what are in the
diffusion the FK TP equation and put in
instead of one goal is that you
destroyed at the beginning something
with heavier tails distribution which is
not here instead of the noise yeah the
noise which has had a heavy pain I don't
think that this move no that's just
that's just individuals having lots of
offspring right got nothing to do with
the spatial motion this the the noise
there has to do with this from the nut
family size it's directly
it's not the movements epidermal common
one was just trying to get better fit
I'm just again it's a little surprising
this model bookies in the limits that
the dispersal is very long very long
it's essentially deterministic we just
thought this place it in the beginning
in the limit that is very short range is
basically termina stick with a little
distance around the edge as the pancake
is growing but in the intermediate
regimes is very strongly stochastic than
domestic back to the nicest brother
spank me the other cars automation
connection with making cut that with the
magnetic so austere mentioned the
challenging day is results on the
results only as a pretty penny so we
have the detailed outlines of program
which covers all of the crossover regime
as well as the as applied behavior and
has very tight battles on these on these
forms of me doing this either log
squared regime when it's something like
log squared plus correction of blah blah
go the logarithm focus on balance and so
there's a lot that one can the one can
do sort of making this heuristic
arguments they can use documents
rigorous you know that there would be
nice because I mean chatterjee and they
have very crude results under is regimes
or it takes yeah he's my students are
here to make fun not very days my
students ah that's a question we love
you get the visa regimes as well made
with my god a different
other questions this like both speakers
and